hey everyone
welcome to direct path number 11.
if you haven't yet check out those first
10 direct path videos
what we are doing in the direct path
series is we
are showcasing the direct path
to god realization the diamond necklace
that is already
around each of our necks yet it remains
for us to recognize it
and we are showcasing that from
many different faces slash
paths of the same one mountain
flat mountain to the one
end and it's a flat mountain
because the flatness is the non-dual
aspect
which is you are already it the diamond
necklace is already around your neck
and the mountain aspect is the process
of the parable of the prodigal son which
is the turning inward of consciousness
and awareness
and itself to god realize
to recognize said diamond around said
neck
and each one of those diamond slash
jewels is a unique
creative artistic expression of the
infinite
and that's the balance of the inward
dynamic
with the outward dynamic
on december 5th
of 2020 i took my first heroic dose of
psilocybin
five grams and during that time
i had yet broken through into
non-duality i had yet to have had my
satori at that time which i experienced
on december 18th
on december 5th what happened was i
tried putting the nature of reality
into words and i made a show about it
which you can check out
on our channel and
when i said describe it try
i was in the heat of the trip
i was in the midst of the depths of the
psychonautics
and it was so gorgeous because i was
trying to
put words on the ineffable
i was trying to distill it into art
and that's when it came through describe
it try
describe our metaphysics describe the
nature of our reality
try to describe the ineffable and the
absolute and what's happening
and so i did and i simply wrote
that the nature is both
in god realization
and out the exterior artistry
so you have both the god realization
becoming aware of awareness
as well as the artistic
expression outward of the infinite
and that's why you have here you have
both the infinity sign
on the inward and on the outward you
have
the artistic palette of all of the
different possible
creative combinatorics of artistry
being expressed outward we will never
be able to finish
creating realities
that we immerse ourselves into as
creative explorations of the infinite
when you have something that's unbounded
so there's no bound
you can't ever finish exploring it so
it's eternal
it's just been eternally creating
these realities these dreams in which
quantum mechanics is showing us
that it is all energy there is no matter
that we recognize that there are an
infinite amount of fluctuations an
infinite amount of modulations of that
energy just like there's an infinite
amount of ways to play music
which is what these realities are and so
we will
never ever come to an end of exploring
all of the possibilities that awareness
or consciousness getting colored by
experience
we will never finish it ever and that's
what this is
and we have this little ranking from the
inward we have the absolute ineffable
the tao that can be named is not the
eternal
dao as lao tzu said so you can't
actually describe
the absolute ineffable it's like the
nirguna brahmin
as in the brahmana without attributes
and then when you go one layer down to
the saguna brahman
or to what many people call god or some
people even called tao
what we say is that the absolute
ineffable
charges awareness or consciousness
and that that is what god realization is
is the recognition that the ineffable
has charged
this consciousness or this awareness to
experience
all of these dreamed creation designs
and so that is what god realization is
on the inward
and then another layer down is the
understanding of
all that is or all inclusive awareness
so that's when you sort of recognize
that the pretty
this is still a very very high end god
realization on the inward side
is to be able to take the perspective
of the observer or the witness or the
consciousness or the awareness
on the scale of the entire dreamed
creation
so it's not only this one dreamed
creation and all
eight billion angles or perspectives
or world views that are being generated
within that consciousness or awareness
yet it is also all of the other creation
designs that are happening all of the
other dreams of the
infinite of the absolute ineffable that
are happening so you have to really use
your imagination and imagine
all of the other creation designs that
are happening simultaneously and the
all-inclusive awareness
is one which can hold the awareness
across all of those
infinite creation designs that are
happening right now
and then one layer below that is just
the i am
presence beingness so that's when you
just recognize your own
god realization right here in this
vehicle this expression of it
you're like okay i'm aware of awareness
in this vehicle from this perspective
and that's great that's an incredible
point of god realization
the next step that you would get to is
the god realization of the all-inclusive
awareness
one step below even the awareness
of awareness itself is when you're sort
of lost in the body
you believe that i am this body i am
this experience i am these perceptions
these beliefs these
objects i am these onion layers of
identity i
am simply a finite biological creature
and absolutely nothing more than that
and that is the cultural hypnosis
and dogma that has been plaguing our
civilization for
millennia because people are kept asleep
thinking that they are finite egoic
separate entities
and that the awareness or the
consciousness is not eternal and also
that it is not
shared amongst us all and so
the first step of awakening is a
recognizing that the consciousness and
awareness is eternal and it's shared
among
us all and that this is just one
expression of infinity that we're
immersed into as a dream and it's
beautiful
and then the layer above that is that
the i am presence beingness becoming
more
and more as it said the light bulb
flickers and then it stays on
for you which is great and then you do
your best to
expand that out to the all-inclusive
awareness of all eight billion
here and then beyond this creation
design to
all of the creation designs and so
that is god realization on the maximum
level of
recognizing the absolute ineffable that
charges awareness consciousness of god
brahman dao
and then also taking out that last thorn
of the charged awareness or
consciousness itself
and that's when you recognize the
absolute the ineffable and there's just
no words at that point
and that's a spectrum from inward to
outward now
when you go all the way inward like in
the parable of the prodigal son
if you go outward first you're going to
hit an egoic breaking point and likely
causing planetary pathology and
ecological disaster
and then you're going to turn inward
anyway and then what happens is once you
god realize
everything outward becomes
effortless action serving and channeling
the absolute highest
morality so the outward expression
becomes effortless
the outward expression is only
disastrous when you believe you're the
body doing the outward expression
so that's why go inward first s
god self-realization first and then
go outward which is the process of
your unique creative expression so you
recognize the
diamond necklace around your neck and
then you
through the absolute highest morality
refract that source light
through your own unique jewel and bring
that artistic creativity
into the world and we'll be doing a lot
more content around the
inward outward duality
because it's a dualistic concession but
it's one of the absolute
best juxtapositions and dualistic
concessions to even
communicate we've been talking about it
a lot
on the program as well with the very
simple dualistic concession
of this is your consciousness slash
awareness that's pure bear
empty pre-coloration that is eternal and
then
this is when your consciousness slash
awareness that is eternal becomes
colored by its unique experience in this
creation design
here you see the consciousness slash
awareness is getting
colored by words and here you see it's
getting colored by art
and so you can see that this is one
observer
this is one god
observer slash witness that is being
colored uniquely
just like we are and you can also see
that in your pupil
our pupil is the god realization that
sameness and then the iris is the
uniqueness
it's so simple it's right under our nose
it's explained like i'm five
so it's the best dualistic concession
that we found thus far as
the juxtaposition of the inward with the
outward
and ask yourself the very fun questions
like and this sort of
further makes the
juxtaposition that we're sharing even
more profound and understandable
which is why would a camera ever turn
inwards
to understand who the videographer is
that's why ramana maharshi was so
persistent and
adamant about understanding who the seer
is because god is the seer
that's why saint francis of assisi said
that
you are seeking that which is
seeing
the more that we recognize that god is
the seer that that
is god realization to become aware of
awareness
itself the more we can make these fun
friendly analogies of
oh i should probably try and understand
who the videographer is
that the camera should turn on itself
and go
inward to understand itself and then it
can go outward flawlessly
morally ethically
another way to think about this is this
is energy that
looks like form appearing
as this atlas talking to an
audience
it's as simple as that energy that looks
like form
which quantum mechanics has verified
appearing
as atlas talking to an
audience so the way that the
infinite absolute ineffable
expresses itself through awareness
consciousness god
dao brahman in being colored
by experience in these dreamed creation
designs
is happening eternally we've been doing
that we're going to keep doing that this
is just one expression of that
and it's energy the most underlying is
energy and it's being modulated it's
being
fluctuated as the
infinite amount of combinations that are
possible in the underlying
structure that then make it a pure ass
form just like music
there's all these infinite combinations
of music
on the underlying structure so that you
when you
hear it you go oh listen to how
different this song is
to how different this song is to how
unique this song is
hear this instrument oh what about this
singer over here
and there's so many infinite
combinations of music
that is the same thing as the infinite
combinations of quantum mechanics
the arrangement of energy which is the
same thing as
the infinite arrangements of dreamed
creation designs
of appearances that have these dreamed
observers
inside of them that are experiencing
them
as god as tao as brahman as the absolute
ineffable
as that awareness consciousness
this is a pretty special direct path
because what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
give you three different
tastes in this one episode so i gave you
that juxtaposition from inward outward
to start and now we're gonna go through
three
different ways of viewing
that direct path of the flat mountain
from the base
to the peak and we're gonna go through
three different examples so it's
basically showcasing
three different faces slash paths and
take whatever resonates with you
in your own process of god realization
of recognizing the diamond necklace
around your neck
and refracting the source light in your
own unique artistic way
so in this first one we're going to talk
about the first step being reclaiming
awareness from
mind this is mind mind is
monkey that's what mind is it's monkey
mind
it's oh my gosh i can't sit still all
i'm doing is thinking i'm lost in my
thoughts i'm lost in my emotions i'm
lost in the experiences
it's the cloud the cloud the cloud the
cloud i'm obsessed with each and every
cloud non-stop
that's the monkey mind and reclaiming
awareness
is juxtaposing the cloud with the sky
and recognizing yourself as the eternal
sky in which all of the clouds appear
the analogies are so simple they're
childlike
the ocean is another one you are the
eternal ocean that is experiencing
all of the different waves
those are all of the colorations you are
the eternal
pupil that is experiencing all of the
different colorations and experience of
the iris
this is just one expression of our
infinitude
and so we reclaim awareness from mind
first
from ego from the contracted finite
separate
biological entity to the
eternal awareness first
then we recognize that awareness is
eternal
so as you reclaim the awareness
usually what happens is you go ah i'm
aware of awareness or i'm
conscious of consciousness i'm now meta
aware or meta conscious
and that's a profound step and then the
next step
is to recognize that that is eternal
which is difficult because you've
you're only used to a finite reality
so you have to then break the
cultural hypnosis of saying that this is
it it's just
one finite reality one finite reality
you have to break that bs and shoot
infinitely out in both directions as
well
in the past and in the future
and that's the recognition that
awareness is eternal
and it's also shared right and that's
when you also recognize that there is
only one observer there's only one
witness
and it's fractaled out in all of these
different configurations in these dreams
like in this one there's eight billion
of
these units or individuals or
multiplicity that are really all
one unity but they're all unique
expressions of it
and so then you recognize that your
pupil is
itself the same shared awareness slash
pupil ex experiencing
the dream in all of its unique
differences from all of the different
countries around the planet
from all of the different cultures
through all of the different languages
through all the different
foods in music and arts and sciences and
engineering
that is what we are that is what this is
wake up wake up
and after you recognize that that
awareness is eternal that that awareness
is shared then you get to the last step
of recognizing that awareness
is a dream
so that's a hard leap to make as well
the
hardest leap though is to get outside
affinity
to infinity once you get to that
eternity and infinity and the awareness
being
shared once you get there then you take
out the last
thorn which is that even awareness
itself
is a dream it's an agent of the infinite
the absolute the ineffable the
infinite
uses awareness which is dreamed
to experience these dreamed creations
so that's one taste let's go
to the next so here's another
face slash path that we'll describe here
in the first step you're going from the
ego to the oneness
okay that means you're going from the
contracted
separate biological finite entity
to the relaxed to the expansive
state of the oneness
and you recognize that that oneness is
eternal that that oneness
is shared once you get to that point you
are really [ __ ] relaxed
you're just chilling you're chilling
because you
know you've become a gnostic being
that's what veda means it means
knowledge
know thyself as the greeks wrote as that
delphic maxim
says you've become god realized
that's what in russians nanya means
that's what the more god realized you
become
the more relaxed you are the more
expansive you've become the more eternal
and infinite you've become because you
know your own true nature you know
our metaphysics
it's no longer a mystery to you because
you've pierced the veilless veil
you've walked through the gateless gate
you've recognized the diamond necklace
that is already around your neck
that's it you got it
that feeling is so profound and
so difficult to describe that satori
moment
we're actually making content here in
l.a as one of our projects
around capturing people's satori moments
and then sharing those with the world
and so if you want to be a part of that
let us know and you can email us
and you can always send that over to us
anytime simulation series
gmail.com and
we'll coordinate that with you sometime
this
year to get that rolling we have lots of
projects and you can support all of them
below by joining the channel and getting
exclusive perks
as well as enabling us to funnel the
success of these projects
so you've recognized that you're moving
away from the finite egoic separate
entity
to the oneness that is eternal and
shared and you're
really relaxed now because you've
recognized your infinitude
and our infinitude and then you
become the sky you become the ocean that
is experiencing the clouds slash the
waves
that's your unique coloration so now you
recognize i am the pupil that's
experiencing the iris of this atlas
character
and you're the pupil that is
experiencing the
the iris of your unique unit your unique
character your unique artistic
expression
so you've went all the way inward to
recognize that ah
got it and then now the outward is
smooth the outward is harmonious the
outward
is high yes possible morality and ethics
effortless action and then you get to
the realization that
even that infinite pupil that is
experiencing eternally different
colorations
is all a dream
and that's it that's the absolute
ineffable
realization this is eternal this is
infinite
this is one expression of it one
creation design one dream
and that we're gonna just keep going
with these we've been doing it we're
gonna keep doing it
that's it that's awakening
that's enlightenment and it's just the
diamond necklace that is already around
your neck it's just the turn
inward to recognize infinity to
recognize
eternity to get yourself out of the
finite
cultural dogma in hypnosis
into what is a leap of faith inward
towards
infinity towards eternity towards your
true metaphysical nature
and even sir roger penrose who won the
nobel prize in physics in 2020
has a cyclic cosmology even the world's
cutting edge physicists are starting to
say
yeah we should answer the question what
was before the big bang and where are we
going after this
yeah no [ __ ] [ __ ] sherlock of course
it's eternal of course it's cyclic
of course it's infinite of course it is
nothing else would make sense if it was
just this finite one and that's it
just this one little blip
it makes zero logical sense
the only logic that makes sense is
eternity the only logic that makes sense
is infinity
and the only logic that makes sense is
all of the creative combinations of the
musical notes
all the creative combinations of the
energetic expressions
all of the creative combinations on the
artist palette
that are then being expressed uniquely
in these dream creation designs
eternally infinitely
that is literally the only thing that
makes logical sense
and this is the thing is that i've now
been
pursuing truth hardcore
full-time for half a decade
and
this is it this is it this is what the
perennial wisdom
is this is what's been talked about
across the mystic traditions for
thousands of years they are all pointing
to the same one
end with different paths slash faces of
the mountain
they're all ice cream but they're just
different flavors of the same ice cream
the statement from john 10 30 i and my
father are one
from the abrahamic tradition is the same
thing as
in the upanishads in the vedic tradition
to say tatvam asi
i am that you are that we are that
they're literally the same thing found
across the planet
the taijitu which is literally the
monast
symbol with the duelist yin yang inside
of it
is in one symbol trying to explain to
you what non-duality the dualistic
concession
and the multiplicity slash individuality
is in one symbol
it just makes so much sense and
modernity is just so hypnotized and
brainwashed
and there's so much
propagation of dogma
and there's so much noise in modernity
there's so much noise it's
absolutely insane how much noise there
is
you have to really look you have to look
it's all available now which is
fantastic
which is what i did in 2020 was i just
went and scooped up as much of what was
available as possible full-time job
and that's why i broke through it's all
available now
you can go and literally whereas for
thousands of years
you could not find where
the most accurate translation of the dao
to ching was
or of the buddhist teachings
and now today you can literally go and
just click a button on the internet and
get an english translated doubted ching
that's
crystal clear from one of the world's
best scholars
you can go and attend a free ten day
vipassana meditation retreat
to undergo the most direct teachings of
the buddha
brought forth by a sengoenka
ten days of just zip shutting up
silencing your mouth
silencing your mind not using technology
and just going inward
to the degree of which you eradicate all
of the dirty roots of your monkey mind
all of the nasty suffering of craving an
aversion
and you become a gnostic being you
become a jedi you have the world's best
nunchi the world's best emotional
intelligence because you've acquired
peak spiritual intelligence you've
acquired the god realization
then everything else just morally
channels out as your unique artistic
entrepreneurial
business art expression flawlessly
frictionlessly woo way effortlessly
and this last taste
which is its own face slash path
is number one individuality to
non-duality so you go from being the
individual
which again is only
part of the cultures around the world
that start at the individual
which is basically your infancy
if you're an infant and your parents and
the community and the culture are saying
you're a separate biological finite
entity i'm a separate biological finite
entity
everybody's a separate biological finite
entity you need to have an ego so that
you can
self deal to yourself so that you can be
safe
and so that you can earn lots and lots
of money
and the more that you are
baptized and indoctrinated into that
cultural drum of hypnosis
the more you're later when you're 20 and
30 years old gonna be like this
is [ __ ] why am i not happy
why am i not peaceful i know there's
more to this
to our metaphysics than this finite
biological
creature [ __ ] so there are
indigenous tribes around the world
that don't even beat the drum
of the finite nonsense upon the infant
being birthed
so the infant never goes into the
ego state they know how to retain
both the god realized union
the inward the yoga the hypnosis
the mysticism while simultaneously
keeping the individuality the unique
expression
of that god realized being outward
whereas if you don't have that inward
first and you only go outward you don't
know what inward you don't know what the
metaphysics are you're just going
outward blindly like in the parable of
the prodigal son you hit a breaking
point
and you turn inward anyway so the first
thing is that
individuality to non-duality and then as
you
hit the non-dual as you pierce the
veilless veil
walk through the gateless gate
experience your satori
everything outward is still going to be
your own unique expression but it's
happening from the non-dual it's
happening from the god rely state
it's not happening from the contracted
finite entity
and then number two here would be ride
the crest
of now slash this so you become
really good upon this god realized state
of infinity of eternity being colored by
experience
that you become really good at riding
the crest
as the surfer you're on the crest of
every single
now of every single this
you're just super present in the
beingness
you laugh at how beautiful the beingness
is you're in
awe at how beautiful the beingness is
you're
addicted to the ecstasy of every single
breath
of the prana of the life force itself
you are
addicted to that it is ecstasy simply
that is ecstasy
and even if a little bit that light bulb
diminishes a bit and you might feel a
little bit
ah a little bit down or sad for a moment
you then suddenly realize
i am god being sad
and then you recognize how funny that is
and
how you're actually infinite and eternal
and then the light bulb comes right back
on again and you're like
wow i am happy and peaceful
i can laugh at myself thinking that i
was
sad a moment ago
it becomes absolutely unbelievable
how much awe and bliss and peace
and ecstasy for every single moment for
all of the now for all of this for
all of the riding on the crest
of every single wave as the ocean itself
as the eternal infinite ocean that we
share
we share the eternal infinite awareness
and lastly it's the beyond everybody and
nobody
so meaning that the oceanicness is the
shared eternal
as we talked about meaning that that's
the everybody we share the everybody
that you and i are that pupil we are
god we are that in our own unique
expressions of it so we are
everybody through that even outside of
this creation design outside of this
dream to all of the other creation
designs and dreams we are
that all-inclusive awareness we are that
that everybody and then when you get to
the realization that it's all a dream
even the awareness itself is a dream
that then you recognize the nobody that
there is nobody here
that this is the fluctuations of an
appearance
that are modulating as an atlas
talking to an audience and that's the
nobody
so you go beyond the everything beyond
the union of everything
beyond the nothingness as well
beyond the nobody's here doing anything
you go beyond both of those to
the absolute ineffable and you just
relax
and you just bathe in the hot shower
of the absolute ineffable
and if you want to ascribe a
adjective you can use the word
perfection
it's just absolute ineffable perfection
and that's the most rely state and then
in the dualistic concession
is where you say oh but there's
suffering and there's well-being
and then we're like yes yes so we're
going to architect
towards maximizing well-being and
prosperity yes
civilization agrees so the dualistic
concession we got it
and then there's the layer of the
individuality of the multiplicity of the
unique expressions outward
as well and there's all of these layers
happening simultaneously
and that's why simultaneity
is the true key
sri aurobindo first taught me that in
the middle of 2020
that simultaneity is key can you hold
both the absolute ineffable
perfection of the non-dual while also
holding the dualistic concession
and the two poles that are in the
rhythmic balanced interchange with each
other in that ascension process
towards the oroboric godhead attractor
while also holding the uniqueness
of each expression of the absolute
ineffable here
each one of us having the unique diamond
or jewel that is refracting the source
light as an artistic contribution
to the big painting to the big dream to
the big lego landscape
that we're all contributing to
it's a decentralized swarm intelligence
that is unilinearly orthogenically like
a symphony
playing towards the oroboric attractor
at the godhead
that's it i hope the direct path 11 was
really helpful for you
i hope you really enjoyed the
juxtaposition of the
inward with the outward and how we can
recognize the simultaneity of going all
the way to the god realization state
and simultaneously going all the way out
in the artistic expression state
and seeing it from all of these
different faces slash
paths to the one end of the flat
mountain
and then taking whatever resonates and
works for you
and then ramping up even more your
as punja said you have this fire that
you're flaming within you
to god realize and as bentino mensaro
said
that your seeking impulse is the truest
thing about you
you are already it yet it remains for
you to recognize it
yet it remains for you to pierce the
veilus veil to walk through the gateless
gate
thank you infinite love adore you so
much thanks for tuning in
like the video if it brought you value
share
the video with other people that it
would resonate with
do that it's critical subscribe if you
haven't
leave a comment below with some of your
thoughts where you're at we'd love to
hear from you
join the community here we have the
exclusive
group chat that's already roaring and
doing really well
and lots of other perks that you can get
by joining the members only here
and we would love for you too because
every single dollar goes directly back
into the actualization of all of our
projects
and
eventually some of the things that i've
learned about being out here in los
angeles is that a lot of the clubs
that the really successful channels have
are actually located off
of youtube because then they get to keep
the vast majority of
the rev share of the
group that decides to help fuel them
energetically in all of their dreams and
aspirations
and then they can create a much more
sort of fluid and harmonic way
of creating incentives and
exclusive perks for those members of
said clubs and so we're also
looking at that whole landscape and
figuring out what the
artistic future trajectory is for the
members and whatnot
but also you know in our ethos is that
the dissemination the distribution of
the awakening content that we produced
will
always be absolutely free of cost
because that's our ethos that's what we
believe
period and so even though there's going
to be some
exclusive videos that are published for
the members only we will also publish
those videos later downstream
for the public for absolutely free
all right that's it thank you so much
i literally got this prop because it is
such an illusion
i'm literally gonna start bringing this
around with me
throughout los angeles through my
meetings
through doing social experiments
with people that come on the program
this is going to be fun
to do during our interviews just the
process of
just looking at the illusion
of the clock itself the illusion of
how we are literally adding symbols that
we made up
to the rotation of the earth on its axis
to the orbit of the earth around the
star
and we said that that these symbols are
true that these symbols
are honest that these symbols are the
nature of reality
but they are not they are the way that
we've colored
this expression of it but they are not
our true metaphysical nature because our
true metaphysical
nature does not have time our true
metaphysical nature is eternal it is
infinite
it is beyond the symbols
and also highly recommend for your
health
and for your wellness get yourself a
tennis ball
they're super cheap they're like a
dollar and just begin
rubbing this on your wrists begin
rubbing it
on your hands especially on your thumbs
take breaks to rub it on your forearms
on your biceps on your triceps
on your trapezoids on your lats
on your thighs your hammies your quads
your calves and then stand on the tennis
ball as well
roll it on the bottom of your foot roll
it on the bottom of your foot
as well and those are those unique
acupuncture points
that really feel good as well so take
good care of your health
as you undergo the process of going all
the way inward to god realization and
all the way outward
as your unique creative artistic
expression take
really good care of your health and your
wellness
i adore you infinitely thank you so much
and
eternal infinite
awareness being colored by
experience
you